When you did retire and when
you retired in the rain?
That was the most honest retirement speech
I've ever heard of box of give ever.
He's just like,
I don't,
I don't have this in me medium
and swimming in there anymore. Um,
I looked pretty bizarre
for myself. Yeah. No,
cause this is what I base my life on
doing. I, when I first started doing it,
I'm a dedicate my life to this stuff.
He gets to see that it's not even,
there's no longer that
happened was pretty weird.
When did you know that you
didn't want to do it anymore?
I'm known years before that, but I
was still being very successful. Yeah.
Like when like what year?
Like do you remember around when
he started thinking it? I remember
probably when I,
what the 2000 area.
So by the time that's post Holyfield yeah,
after and you, you're just, you it done
too much. I was just winning. I'm winning.
Beating guys. You know, guys get hit or
something and from gotta be feel scared.
Yeah. What did, what did you have in mind?
Like that's the hardest thing right? To,
to swing from that to the next thing.
Like how do you take,
how do you take this crazy exciting
life? No, I thought I lifted.
Let me if get high for a while and
figured it out. That was the plan.
Yeah. I mean party for a while
to figure this stuff out.
What did you figure out? Okay. Um,
uh, I wanted to do other things.
So I started my wife,
um,
arranged for me to be the
death being on stage that the,
she created the show.
Yeah.
That's a brilliant idea because you're
also the first fighter that ever did that.
Cause many fighters have great stories,
but very few of them we've ever,
I don't think anybody besides you
was ever put it in the did it man.
It's just amazing. We did in Monaco,
we didn't own, we did it, um,
uh,
amount of various places and now I can't
believe that people want to see this
though. Well like I said,
the documentary was amazing.
So people want to hear the live version
of you talking about it and the see you
live in person.
Cause the first time we did it,
the first time we did it, I'm
on Broadway Day, day three,
we were really as sure about
how it's gonna turn out.
So we invited all of our friends.
We had taken the,
gave all to our friends and people we
love like names and we pulled them to the
show. And so when we started they
started laughing. Everybody, if I left,
I ran in my right wife around.
I still got the baby.
What's going on and listening. Okay.
I didn't want the show to be a comedy.
They turned out to your comment with hard,
gritty show about a tough guy. Right.
He made it through his toughness
and he just came up on me.
He was talking about myself,
how much a smoke I am, you know,
and they loved it. Well I think that was
part of it. It's cause like they all,
everybody knew you were this tough guy,
but they didn't know that you can be so
self deprecating and have so much fun
with it all. You know? That's
why people loved it. Yeah.
They're doing the writing for my moving
and stuff. I haven't seen anything,
but it's going to be pretty wow.
Who's playing you in a movie
on the various people you know?
Most likely when Jamie, Jamie,
Jamie Foxx to do it. He could do it.
He could do anything.
That guy could be the fucking president.
United States.
He could be a pilot that goes to the moon.
He could do whatever the fuck you
want. Want him to do it. Yeah,
he could do whatever he wants. He'll
probably bulk up like crazy too to do it.
It's going to be really, wow.
Yeah. Jamie could pull it off.
Michael Jai white pulled it off. Michael
Jai White didn't do it like Jamie. I,
I dunno. I thought it didn't do a bag.
A lot of people that make what he did,
but I thought you did a good job. He, I
loved him and spawn. He's a great guy.
Do you know him well? No. He's a
great guy. Great Guy. Very smart guy.
Very humble guy.
Really,
really intelligent and a great
martial artists to Michael Jai White.
It was a kill Kachin a karate
black belt is bad when the fight,
the fight in the UFC. Now when he was
fighting, there was no UFC around,
but he did a lot of karate
tournaments and stuff. It's very good.
I watched him train before. He's legit.
Very legit. But like I said, real,
real good guy. But yeah, I
agree. Jamie Foxx, man. Jamie
Foxx is on another planet.
He's just got this level of competence
and skill and artistry in his singing and
his comedy and his acting. He
could do anything. He could play.
You just going to hang
out with you for awhile.
I don't know what he's gotta
he's gotta hang out with you.
So be pretty awesome. He's got to hang out
with you got to absorb it, right? Yeah.
To see what, how that works out. Are
you going to be the kiss consultant?
You're going to be like pitch. I would
never said that. I would like to say that.
Yeah.
But for some reason they just, um, they
have their Hollywood ways of doing thing.
Yeah. You know what I mean? They make
it come out of Hollywood ish, I guess.
Cause some think that it's just,
it's just really wild.
How did they try to switch it
to appear? Um, cause Annabelle,
right? Yeah. They tried to change the
story and no one else I realized too,
when Hollywood perspective from things,
the religious is just still unbelievable.
Yeah. So it's really, it's unbelievable.